à sec -- aucun mortier entre les joints.
On joint les pierres à sec --
fantastique
et toujours solide aujourd'hui.
Ou parfois, dans les montagnes,
les gens construisent des ponts suspendus,
pour traverser des canyons vertigineux
en utilisant des lianes.
Cette fois, c'est au Pérou.
En utilisant de l'herbe qui pousse là-bas
et en en faisant des cordes pour bâtir ces ponts.
Et saviez-vous qu'ils les reconstruisent chaque année ?
Car bien sûr, l'herbe n'est pas un matériau durable.
Donc ce pont n'a pas changé depuis l'époque Inca.
Et les ponts peuvent être le symbole de leur lieu.
Bien sûr, le Golden Gate et Sydney sont bien connus.
À Mostar, le pont était synonyme du nom de la ville,
à tel point que pendant la guerre en 1993,
quand le pont a été détruit,
la ville a presque perdu son identité jusqu'à sa reconstruction.
Et les ponts sont des caractéristiques énormes dans notre paysage --
pas qu'énormes, ils sont parfois petits --
et ce sont des éléments très importants,
et je crois que nous nous devons de rendre nos ponts beaux.
Heureusement, c'est souvent le cas.
Pensez au superbe Viaduc de Millau dans le sud de la France.
L'ingénieur français Michel Virlogeux et l'architecte anglais Lord Foster
ont collaboré pour produire quelque chose
qui est une combinaison prodigieuse d'architecture et d’ingénierie.
Ou le pont de Salginatobel de Robert Maillart dans les montagnes suisses --
absolument sublime.
Ou plus récemment,
la passerelle de Laurent Ney, belle et quelque peu délicate
pour le château anglais de Tintagel.
Ils sont beaux et spectaculairement conçus
et des comme ça, il en faut plus.
Les ponts peuvent être rangés dans trois catégories,
selon la nature de la structure
qu'ils adoptent comme structure principale.
Donc, le cintrage, bien sûr, quand on tord une poutre --
donc, poutres et cintrage.
Ou la compression, le principal mode de travail pour une arche.
Ou pour les très longs ponts, il faut être léger,
nous reviendrons là-dessus,
donc on utilise de la tension, des câbles --
les ponts suspendus.
Et de nombreuses variétés différentes sont possibles.
Les ingénieurs ont un grand potentiel d'innovation et d'inventivité
et pour développer diverses formes autour de ces catégories.
Mais les avancées technologiques arrivent assez lentement dans mon monde,
croyez-le ou non,
comparé aux évolutions technologiques dans la téléphonie mobile,
en informatique, en technologie numérique, etc.
Dans notre monde, celui de la construction,
ces évolutions semblent indéniablement lentes.
La raison de cette lenteur peut être résumée en un mot :
le risque.
Nous, les ingénieurs, gérons les risques.
Notre devoir est de sécuriser la structure.
C'est notre job.
Et lorsque nous concevons de tels ponts,
je dois prendre en compte la possibilité qu'il y ait plus de poids sur un côté
ou que la résistance soit trop faible de l'autre côté.
Et tout cela n'est d'ailleurs généralement pas prévisible
et complique ainsi les calculs.
Nous devons donc faire en sorte
qu'il y ait une marge adéquate pour la sécurité entre les deux, bien sûr.
Il n'y a rien, je dois vous le dire, qui soit parfaitement sûr.
Contrairement à l'opinion populaire,
le risque zéro n'existe pas.
Les ingénieurs doivent bien effectuer leurs calculs
qui assurent que ces marges existent,
et la société s'attend à ça.
Ainsi, c'est d'autant plus alarmant quand des choses comme ça arrivent.
Je ne vais pas parler des raisons de ces tragédies,
mais elles font partie des causes
de la lenteur des évolutions technologiques.
Personne ne veut que cela n'arrive.
Les clients ne veulent pas voir leurs projets entachés, évidemment.
Et ils veulent quand même de l'innovation.
L'innovation est vitale.
En tant qu'ingénieur, c'est inscrit dans mon ADN.
C'est dans mon sang.
Je ne pourrais pas être un bon ingénieur si je ne cherchais pas à être innovant,
mais nous devons l'être en position de force, avec du savoir
et de la compréhension.
Il ne faut pas sauter dans l'inconnu,
et notre civilisation a appris de ses erreurs depuis la nuit des temps --
les ingénieurs plus que tous.
Cette vidéo peut vous être familière --
celle du fameux effondrement du pont du détroit de Tacoma
à Tacoma dans l'État de Washington,
en 1940.
Ce pont a été nommée « Gertie la Galopante »,
parce qu'elle -- elle ?
Un pont féminin ? Je ne sais pas.
Elle chancelait comme ça depuis assez longtemps,
et regardez ce mouvement de torsion.
Le pont était bien trop souple.
Il a été conçu par un gars appelé Leon Moisseiff,
habitué à concevoir des ponts suspendus,
mais il a ici poussé les limites juste un peu trop loin
et en a payé le prix.
Heureusement, personne n'a été tué.
Mais cet effondrement a stoppé le développement des ponts suspendus,
et ce, très brusquement.
Pendant 10 ans, personne n'a pensé à refaire un pont suspendu.
Il n'y en avait aucun.
Et quand ils ont émergé dans les années 50,
la réaction fut démesurée mais légitime,
une réponse de surprotection à ce qu'il s'était passé.
Mais pour ceux apparus au milieu des années 60,
le changement était radical --
une innovation, une évolution technologique radicale.
Voici le Pont de la Severn, au Royaume-Uni.
Remarquez la section transversale profilée avec aérodynamisme,
au centre, là.
Une boîte le rend aussi très résistant à la torsion --
le mouvement de torsion du pont de Tacoma ne pourrait pas arriver ici.
Et il est aussi très léger
et comme nous allons le voir,
être léger est très important pour les longues travées,
et tout le monde semble vouloir qu'elles soient de plus en plus longues.
Pour l'instant, la plus longue est au Japon.
Elle fait un peu moins de 2 000 mètres -- une seule travée.
Presque deux kilomètres.
Le pont du détroit d'Akashi.
Nous travaillons actuellement sur un pont turc un peu plus long,
et nous avons conçu celui de Messine en Italie,
qui attend juste d'être construit, un jour,
qui sait quand.
(Rires)
Je vais revenir sur Messine dans un instant.
Mais l'autre type de pont à longue travée qui utilise le principe de tension
est le pont à haubans,
et on en voit beaucoup.
En fait, les Chinois en construisent énormément en ce moment.
Le plus long de ces ponts est russe, le pont de l'île Roussky, à Vladivostok --
il fait plus de 1 100 mètres.
Mais revenons à la question de longue travée et de légèreté.
Utilisons le pont de Messine en exemple.
Le graphique au milieu représente la capacité des câbles principaux --
c'est ce qui fait tenir le pont --
la capacité des câbles principaux.
Et remarquez que 78% de cette capacité
est utilisée uniquement pour que le pont reste en place.
Seulement 22% de sa capacité --
c'est moins d'un quart --
est utilisée pour les charges,
tout ce que le pont doit soutenir :
la voie ferrée, la route, etc.
Et en fait,
plus de 50% de cette charge --
de cette charge morte --
est celle des câbles eux-mêmes.
Juste les câbles, sans le tablier du pont.
Si nous pouvions faire des câbles plus légers,
les travées seraient plus longues.
Actuellement, si nous utilisons des fils d'acier haute résistance,
la travée peut, en pratique, atteindre environ cinq ou six kilomètres
si on donne tout.
Mais si nous utilisions de la fibre de carbone dans ces câbles,
nous pourrions atteindre plus de 10 kilomètres.
C'est assez spectaculaire.
Mais de longues travées ne sont pas forcément la solution partout.
Ça coûte très cher
et implique beaucoup de défis différents à relever,
et nous optons souvent pour des travées multiples
pour franchir de larges estuaires ou des détroits.
Mais bien sûr, si ce détroit était situé comme celui de Gibraltar,
ou dans ce cas, comme celui de la Mer Rouge,
nous construirions en effet des ponts à travées longues et multiples
et cela serait vraiment spectaculaire, n'est-ce pas ?
Je ne pense pas que j'en verrai un terminé dans ma vie,
mais ça vaudra surement la peine d'attendre pour certains d'entre vous.
Bien, je vais vous parler de quelque chose que je trouve vraiment formidable.
Voici un pont suspendu à travées multiples qui traverse les eaux profondes de Norvège
sur lequel nous travaillons en ce moment.
« Eaux profondes » signifie que les fondations sont d'un prix exorbitant.
Donc ce pont flotte.
Un pont suspendu à travées multiples, qui flotte.
Il existe déjà des ponts flottants, mais rien de tel.
Il tient sur des pontons flottants
ancrés au fond de la mer et maintenus sous l'eau --
donc, tirés sous l'eau contre les forces de flottabilité.
Et pour les rendre stables,
les sommets des tours doivent être rattachés,
sinon toute la construction oscillerait
et personne ne voudrait y circuler.
Mais je suis très enthousiaste
car si vous pensez à tous les endroits dans le monde
où l'eau est si profonde
que personne n'a jamais considéré y construire un pont
ou quoique ce soit d'autre,
ce pont ouvre des possibilités.
Il est donc construit par l'Administration Norvégienne des Routes,
mais j'ai vivement hâte de savoir
où cette technologie va permettre le développement --
pouvoir avancer ensemble,
bâtir des communautés.
Maintenant, et le béton ?
Le béton a parfois mauvaise réputation,
mais dans les mains de personnes comme Rudy Ricciotti,
voyez ce qu'on peut en faire.
C'est ce qu'on appelle du béton fibré à ultra hautes performances.
Un peu long comme terme.
Un terme fait pour nous, les ingénieurs.
(Rires)
Mais ce qu'on fait avec --
c'est un matériau très résistant et durable dans le temps
et le rendu sculptural peut être splendide.
Oui, le béton peut être attrayant.
Nous pourrions parler de bien d'autres technologies
qui voient le jour,
les robots, l'impression 3D, les IA et tout ça,
mais je préfère revenir sur ce à quoi j'ai fait allusion plus tôt.
Nos ponts doivent être fonctionnels, oui.
Être sûrs, absolument.
Ils doivent être pratiques et durables.
Mais je crois vivement qu'ils doivent être élégants ;
qu'ils doivent être beaux.
Nos ponts sont conçus pour durer.
Nous les concevons pour plus de 100 ans.
Ils seront là pendant un sacré long moment.
Personne ne se souviendra de leur prix.
Personne ne se souviendra de leur retard de deux mois.
Mais s'ils sont laids ou insipides,
ils seront toujours laids ou insipides.
(Rires)
Les ponts --
la beauté enrichit la vie.
N'est-ce pas ?
Elle améliore notre bien-être.
La laideur et la médiocrité font l'effet inverse.
Et si nous continuons à créer des environnements médiocres et laids --
et je pense que nous y devenons insensibles --
si nous perpétuons ça,
cela s'assimile à du vandalisme à grande échelle,
ce qui est totalement inacceptable.
(Applaudissements)
Voici un pont à Lyon en France,
que la ville a obtenu via une compétition de design.
Et je pense qu'il faut commencer à parler à ces gens qui pensent nos ponts,
et nos structures,
car la source du projet est souvent la clé.
Une compétition est un moyen d'acquérir un bon projet
mais pas le seul.
Énormément de projets sont proposés partout,
qui ont des préjugés à l'encontre des beaux designs.
Donc oui, la technologie avance doucement quelquefois dans mon monde.
Mais tout ce qu'on peut en faire m'enthousiasme.
Sauver des vies en Afrique rurale,
ou étendre les limites technologiques des longs ponts,
ou juste traverser la route d'à côté.
J'espère que nous continuerons à construire des choses belles et élégantes
qui sauvent des vies et créent des communautés.
Merci.
(Applaudissements)